a lot of interesting discussions on the
David Pakman show
reddit which you can find at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT
sumner breeze posted vote blue no matter
who except for racists New York
billionaire mayor's who stop and frisk
minorities senile dementia patients who
were creepy to women and want to cut
Social Security CIA agents who fix bread
prices lie about supporting single-payer
health care and are funded by
billionaires and anyway the point is we
we get to so who do we have left folks a
viewer who clearly is concerned that I
guess litmus tests being applied in the
Democratic primary ignoring that maybe
all of these folks are better than Trump
will lead to a trump reelection an
interesting post although I'm not a
hundred percent sure of the message as
I've said before if the candidate is
better than Trump I will vote for the
candidate use their music writer posted
will a contested convention screw over
Bernie Sanders again saying
with so many contenders fighting for
delegates it's looking increasingly
likely that no one candidate will
receive a plurality of the delegates I
think they mean a majority if Bernie
ultimately wins the most delegates but
falls short of the 51% requirement does
this mean the DNC super-delegates will
likely be given the chance to flock to
one of the establishment friendly
candidates I'm wondering if a contested
convention pretty much means we are
screwed all over again the answer is
probably yes but it's still early we've
had two primaries we've got a third one
coming soon a fourth one then Super
Tuesday it is true that the most likely
scenario right now and we'll get into
this in more detail according to 538 is
a situation where no one gets 50% plus
one that doesn't necessarily lead to a
contested convention with a second round
of voting because there can be
negotiations that happen between the
last primary and the first boat where
one candidate will direct their
delegates to support somebody else but
yes if it goes to a second round that is
the most like
scenario lastly a post on the reddit
that says yoy is Tulsi still here for
some no shot candidates I get their
reasons steyr has a lot of money Clos
Bashar had good results in New Hampshire
Warren is somewhat viable but not for
long
but Tulsi there are more reasons to stay
in than winning I get that media
attention name recognition but why stay
in when you are only losing you will be
known as a loser and progressives will
see you as someone taking votes away
from Bernie listen anybody who wants to
run for president should run anybody who
wants to stay in should stay in I
actually don't really worry much about
Tulsi getting out at this point like
she's literally polling zero delegates
she has a path to zero delegates she's
not on the debate stage
I don't know that she's running ads I
don't see or hear anything about Tulsi
except people tweeting me so I'm not
even really worried about what tools he
does join the discussion at david
pakman.com slash reddit do you feel like
you just don't have enough time to
become as intellectually well-rounded as
you would like to be that they're just
not enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free for a
week and get 25% off a subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work
I've just finished listening to upheaval
by Jared Diamond Jared Diamond a
tremendous author whose work I've
previously recommended excellent book
looking at some of modern history's
biggest national crises to figure out
how different countries ended up in such
precarious situations Blinky's has
totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety
when I can but there are simply just so
many books that I want to read and would
not have the time for if it weren't for
blankets they have books on politics
economics philosophy science you name it
you can try it out yourself totally free
for a week and get 25% off if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video like the
rest of us I bet you're going into 2020
thinking about what you didn't get
around to in 2019 and your goals for the
new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you